[Music]
I'm Ernest the glory welcome to Ferrara
bakery Ferrara's is in the heart of New
York's Little Italy and we specialize in
southern Italian pastries of pleasure
city of Vienna a cannoli of what I
research goes back to almost like a
Turkish cannelloni which has a neat
filling with cheese and it made its way
down through Sicily and then I guess
some man wanted to make a suite for some
woman and he fried this shell and made a
sweet that got the cream so it's this
creamy dessert with a crispy shell the
cannoli dough is made up of low fruit
flour Marsala wine water egg yolks and
sugar and it's very very dry dull and
that's gonna help us later on in the
firing process to develop the blisters
once we mix the dough we put on the
table we want to work to do a little bit
with our hands we're gonna finish school
to get out
then we're gonna square the go and we're
gonna roll a thinner and thinner I would
say maybe it's five sheets of paper then
we stamp our shape once we stand by
shape it's in an oval we roll it on the
tube which is called a canola and then
we fry it takes approximately three
minutes and we don't want to ever go
below 350 degrees you'll have a soggy
product and once we try the cannoli you
want to pull them off the dowel as soon
as you can because they're expanded when
they get cold and contract and they can
grab one to the two we cool it and then
we fill it with a sweet we've got the
cream we finish it with a little bit of
powdered sugar so it opens the face
what's up on the tongue and the flavor
come it's come full you also make a
chocolate dipped cannoli we put the fork
inside the collar and we create it
through a bath of chocolate and that has
to sit and shell
so tremendous amount of labour in the
chocolate cuddly but people love them we
incorporated in 1892 mr. farrar my
great-uncle and mr. scope was my
great-grandfather they rented a spot
they made coffee they said oh we have a
great business here and under the papers
I love cannolis because it's my family
tradition and it brings so many smiles
to so many people's face and coming from
our family sharing food is a way we say
we love you so we love to cook
[Music]